we were talking earlier about changing
your family tree it's a compounding
effect not just
financially financially mathematically
it's a compounding effect in the
decision making you make different
decisions
two and three and four steps later
because of those first decisions so i
love to see how that can have a ripple
effect for the rest of your life
and i'm starting to do some writing on
this millionaire stuff
because i'm starting to see some nuances
with our baby step millionaire community
um and that's what i'm calling it for
right now i may change the name of it
but i mean that's that's i'm starting to
and one thing i've noticed is is that
the millionaire
that sometimes what keeps people off the
track from being a millionaire is they
want to try to be a billionaire
and a bill billionaires are a billion is
a thousand million
and uh in the forbes 400 i i got to look
it up fresh i it's been
a year since i've looked it up i need to
look it up again but in the forbes 400
it was that almost all the forbes 400
are billionaires now
the 400 wealthiest people in america
used to be three-quarters of them were
but i think they just about all are now
and like 70 of them are first-generation
billionaires
but the way you become a billionaire is
different
okay explain that then the way you
become a millionaire because the typical
millionaire the one to five million
first thing that happens to billionaires
is obviously first they become a
millionaire right
before they become billionaires right
but the difference from jumping from
five million
to a thousand million is a big jump
yeah okay so you get that first five
million the way we're talking about here
walking the baby steps that's a baby
step millionaire but very few
but billionaires didn't use their 401k
and they paid for a house to become a
billionaire right in almost every case
they
um started a business
and took it public or didn't
but they uh the business uh
somehow there was a business leverage
angle okay you know uh
you know uh to where you know oprah owns
this massive media empire
and that's what made her a billionaire
it wasn't getting paid to do the oprah
show right
she she used her entrepreneurial skills
behind the scenes to build and she's a
billionaire mm-hmm
uh or uh the kathy family you know
chick-fil-a yeah
true kathy passed away but he was a
billionaire and
the kids are uh but that's the value of
chick-fil-a
yeah it gives them that the business
value
uh the hobby lobby family the green
family again it was the value of that it
wasn't working a job and loading money
in the 401k they got them there
so they worked the job and loaded the
401k and along the way they became
millionaires
but then the way they make this huge
leap but the difference but people have
in their mind when they say wealthy
what billionaires do you know private
jets right
expensive cars six houses millionaires
don't have any of that
millionaires don't have private jets and
expensive cars and four houses yeah they
don't
billionaires do right but if you try to
jump from where you are
to billionaire you make a lot of
mistakes on get rich quick
yeah yeah because you're skipping you
got to do the tortoise
first yeah yeah and win the race to get
in that one to five
and then that positions you to do some
of these other things
yeah and and you can go big from there
it's interesting but uh
uh you know it it but if you try to if
you think of wealthy as a billionaire
then it's unattainable number one number
two you start doing stupid stuff to try
to get there before you do the basics
yeah so do the baby step millionaire
first then start thinking about
billionaire level stuff